whole premise of wokeness is there is no
spiritual life there's only Power
everything that we believe in is power
femininity is power masculinity the
constructs of power and so they can't
say anything you can't you can't say
anything about what it is to be a human
being you know I've always thought what
would it what would happen if you told a
story in which a woman character starts
out as a powerful business woman and
then says you know what I don't want to
do this I want to make a family I want
to I want a man to take care of me so I
can do this you know you can't make that
movie what's going on with the movies I
can't remember I mean there's the odd
movie that comes along I go oh I'd like
to see that but nothing really compels
me like it used to yeah what's going on
well there's there's two things one is
that art forms have a natural life cycle
uh you know they can come back they
don't necessarily die forever but they
rise up at their Peak usually very early
on to me the peak year of the movies is
1939 I mean and what happens at that
Peak is that the popular movies and the
critically acclaimed movies are the same
movie so when you get it when you get oh
I see where this is going well it's true
you know you've got an era like where
the theater is thriving Shakespeare is
the popular playwright uh you get the
novels are thriving Dickens you know one
of the greatest novel novelists ever is
also the best-selling novelist 1939 if
you look at the 10 Oscar nominees
they're also some of the greatest films
ever made including the Wizard of Oz and
you know I don't know if Gone With the
Wind was that year but it's almost that
year
um
Mr Smith one of the Frank Capital
as an art form ages out
they split into uh popular trash
like these Marvel movies these superhero
movies and these kind of tiny little
intellectual exercises that the critics
think are oh so important but the rest
of us can't stay awake through and
that that's the one thing that's
happening it's simply a matter of the
art form aging out and a lot of that
energy went over to TV in the 2000s the
early 2000s I remember watching a show
here called the shield and thinking oh
gee they're doing everything I did in
the golden the second golden age of
mystery writing I was writing characters
just like this and now they've all moved
over to TV and that and we had 20 years
of great TV here I mean it was really
brilliant stuff
but the other thing is this this idea of
of wokeness which is actually uh a very
deep we use it as a slogan
uh as a catch word but it's actually a
very deep
philosophical moment it is the bottom of
atheistic philosophy and it's impossible
to make a good story out of it because
it has no inner life it the whole the
whole premise of wokeness is there is no
spiritual life there's only Power
everything that we believe in is power
femininity is power masculinity the
constructs of power and so they can't
say anything you can't you can't say
anything about what it is to be a human
being you know uh there is we're talking
about there are no women characters I've
always thought what would it what would
happen if you told a story in which a
woman character starts out as a powerful
business woman and then says you know
what I don't want to do this I want to
make a family I want to I want a man to
take care of me so I can do this you
know you can't make that movie and yet
that is the movie right you can't make a
movie where a guy comes to town and
builds a business
and he's the hero of the movie you know
because it's all about power so if he
has power he must be the bad guy when
you get rid of the spiritual life
there's only Power and and that's not a
good story wow you know what you're
investment of uh to I don't know if
you're familiar with him he was a KGB
Defector uh from the Soviet Union yeah
uh in in the like he has lectures on
YouTube and this is uh this is one of
the things he talked about how in the
movies at certain point uh the police
the generals the army they all became
the bad guys the criminal is the good
one the the KGB uh not not the KGB the
army colonel he's always the dumb one
that whatever but I want to come back to
the first of those two Andrew because
what you're talking about is a perfect
metaphor for politics more broadly
because you you have a an elite
that is so up its own us it is
completely out of touch with ordinary
person and so which is typical by the
way right well right and so that's why
the movie or that that there's the
screen the screenshots from like the
Rotten Tomatoes ratings for comedy shows
like a Dave Chappelle latest show or a
movie and now their their parody is on
themselves where like critics 100 you
know uh for the for they like or dislike
something and it's the opposite way for
the ordinary person right and it seems
to me like it's not just about aging out
it's about a fundamental Detachment of
the people in in a in like in this case
in Hollywood from the people who they're
supposed to provide services or content
or whatever it is but this is how this
is how an art form dies it is it is a
coagulation of power in a way you know
we're sitting a few miles from
Washington in Washington you can go to
Georgetown named after Washington and
walk down the street that used to be
called Washington Street with inside of
the Washington Monument in the middle of
Washington DC so you can get the picture
that George Washington's had a lot of a
big effect on this
um on this country and the thing that is
Washington's signal moment is having
defeated the British in this defeated
the greatest Empire on Earth with this
ragtag band of you know half starlings
uh that wandering around in the snow
he's got
he's the king of a continent he can be
the king of a continent there was
nothing to stop him and he takes he goes
to uh somewhere in Maryland and
Annapolis and he turns over his sword to
the civilian Powers because he believed
that much in the idea of The Sovereign
people
that also just like you said has aged
out so that at that moment the most
popular man in America was also the best
man in America and probably one of the
best men who ever lived you know he was
like but he was also now like the people
who are popular are completely detached
from the the power and the people who
are powerful are completely detached
from the people
um the Advent of Donald Trump which even
at the time I said you know this is a
tragic moment when it takes a man like
Donald Trump to speak for the people
because everybody and you saw the way
the power Just Came to shut him down
this is not about whether Trump's a nice
person or a good person or anything like
that it's simply what he represented to
people for for 50 years
50 years the powers that be told people
in this country you stink your country
stinks your religion stinks your cut the
color of your skin stinks everything
about your history it stinks you know
like your God doesn't exist
and then they thought well why did they
elect Donald Trump
you know my feeling was you're lucky
they didn't show up outside your house
with a torch and a pick Pitchfork and
toss you into the Potomac you know this
was the nice thing electing Donald Trump
was the nice thing to do so you're
absolutely right I mean I think that
um as as people
people think their way out of morality
as as they think their way out of
your individuality the importance of
your individuality it's easy for me to
feel my individuality and my reality but
you have to have to sort of really think
about it to think oh you know maybe that
guy sitting across from you is just as
important to himself as I am to me and
and that we're both equally important to
God then you have art then you have the
enlightenment then you know once you get
that idea then you have all the kind of
beautiful things that that Europe
produced and once you lose that idea you
lose everything and and I think you're
absolutely right that kind of
coagulation of of power money uh
political ideas in in an aristocracy
that does not care anymore for the
people that has no no bless oblige is
the way a country ages out as well and
you can see it but going back to this
idea of the movies where the values that
America used to embody and use to
celebrate if you think about the movies
of the 80s and 90s strength resilience
Independence taking responsibility for
yourself
you look at the movies now and they just
it's unrecognizable you think to
yourself what message are you trying to
send me how are you trying to inspire me
yes well that's well that is a you know
it's an amazing thing the people who
built the movie industry the people who
made the movies I love and probably you
love as well many of them were
immigrants many of them were Jews and
they love this place they loved America
I mean because they'd seen what the rest
of the world was like especially the
Jewish guys they knew exactly what what
they had going on in America and they
were liberal in the sense that they
wanted to be included
but they were businessmen who thought
their business depended on the audience
liking what they did so if the audience
was Christian they give them Christians
they have a scene where the Christian
guy would be nice to a Jew and then and
you know that would give you a good
feeling and they would say yes we're
part of this country too and everybody
said yes you are
that that was great stuff but they loved
they may not have loved the people uh
individually but they love them as the
audience they were their source of their
income they were the source of their
popularity their power everything and
they served them they served the people
partially because the studio system was
destroyed by the courts
the essentially the inmates took over
the Asylum uh in Hollywood this is part
of the the deaths uh throws of the
industry but
you had this moment when they lost the
studio system Studios had a monopoly
they had a monopoly on theaters the
court said you can't they it was a trust
busting case and they destroyed that
so ultimately now
power rested with actors and not with
businessmen and so you got you have
actors who were great businessmen like
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Tom Cruise
they're great businessmen but they're
still not about the people those are bad
examples because Cruz and Schwarzenegger
actually are about the people but so
many of these guys you know you make a
movie even an Oscar to a movie like what
was it called Moonlight was that was
what it was called it was when
oscar-winning film about a black gay guy
discovering that he's gay you know
it wasn't a bad film but it was like a
slice of Life about this you know like
this and then you think about Gone With
the Wind you think about the movies that
have won Oscars
gave you all of life you know they gave
you so many think Casablanca I mean that
that movie you can watch that movie
today you can watch it twice in a row
today and it'll still break your heart
whereas you know a black gay guy in the
in the ghetto is an interesting story
I'll watch that once you know but it's
not it's not telling me something that I
need to know to get forward in life
whereas the fact that sometimes you have
to give up the thing you love for a
greater cause is something I needed to
know the movies shaped you know it's
funny
the Arts shaped me you know I I wasn't
happy at home I had a bad relationship
with my dad I went to the first to
novels and then to movies for male role
models and I found Bogart John Wayne
these you know Raymond Chandler's Philip
Marlow the great detective guy Sam Spade
um
and they taught me these simple things
you know they taught me how to walk they
taught me you know how to what you what
you would sacrifice for they taught me
that you would sacrifice for something
during the pandemic recently there was
this moment when Donald Trump got
covered and he came back to the White
House
and he said I've now I've had covet
Don't Be Afraid don't let it dominate
your life
and there is this Montage that I play on
my show from time to time of the news
media coming out going what a horrible
thing to do of course you should be
afraid of course this this could kill
you what's wrong you know that and I I
don't know if I was the last person in
America with all those movies in my head
saying wait a minute you know there are
there are things that are more important
than dying you know like slavery like
being like losing your freedom like
losing your dignity like you know losing
the chance to be the thing that you want
to be people have died for all those
things through time and yet here with
the news that was the news media one of
them after another say no no no that
mean awful Donald Trump you know you
must be afraid you must be afraid and
then they sit around going why would
anybody vote for Donald Trump you know
these are the things we learned from the
movies uh and we learned them before
that from you know British novels I
think more than anything else uh and
these are the things that are gone
in my opinion from a world without God
because why would you why would you risk
your life
if there's nothing Beyond yourself you
know why would you risk your life for
anything if there's nothing Beyond
yourself if something doesn't have a
quality of the Eternal to it uh like
Freedom like uh you know justice of
those things why would you die for them
if uh if everything is just material
you know you're here you're gone and
that's the reason I'm such a huge Arthur
Miller fan the playwright Arthur Miller
and his wife for me the the play The
Crucible resonates harder than ever
especially now yeah when you have
Proctor and he gives John Procter at the
end when he's about to he's about to die
and he refuses
to
give give up the anybody else and he
says but leave me my name that's all I
have that's all that any man has yes and
and then think you know with Andrew
Cuomo who has made a hero he was the
governor of New York yeah and he was
made into a hero the anti-trump yeah and
he said you know we have to do all this
stuff because it's death and nothing is
worse than death death is death and
death when you're dead you're dead you
know who are these people like like run
and hide everybody and and you know this
is this is kind of the instrument of
power everything is a catastrophe
everything is an emergency the climate
is an emergency you go like you know
it's it's a little warm today oh my it's
an emergency give me more power you know
racism is an emergency reason this is a
health emergency you know give us more
power uh the covet is emerging give us
more power there's always back to that
you know it's always basically they're
gonna take care of you
foreign